Ask most movie fans, “What was the first
‘talkie’?”
The most frequent reply tends to be “The
Jazz Singer” starring Al Jolson.
This is a “sort of” correct answer, but
not really.
The earliest “sound” movies were made
by synchronizing motion pictures to phonograph
records.
In 1926, (a year before “The Jazz Singer”)
Warner Brothers re-released the previously
silent film “Don Juan” with a soundtrack
recording done by the New York Philharmonic
Orchestra.
Warner Brothers also released the first actual
all-talking, feature-length motion picture
in 1928.
It was called “Lights of New York.”
The following year, Twentieth Century Fox
released “In Old Arizona,” the first all-talkie
feature with sound directly recorded on the
film.
“The Jazz Singer” was actually a silent
movie with poorly synchronized musical numbers
and a few sentences of spoken words.
One of the main reasons “The Jazz Singer”
is such a legendary film is because of its
star- the immortal Al Jolson.
Jolson was, by all accounts, the “Elvis
Presley” of his time.
At the time “The Jazz Singer” was released,
Jolson was one of the biggest stars in show
business.
(As a sidebar, Jolson did make several films
after “The Jazz Singer,” but none came
close to it in popularity or historical significance.)
Many current movie fans are familiar, at least
somewhat, with Jolson and his show biz legacy,
but he has few current-day fans.
This is partly because Jolson’s schtick
was the “blackface” act, which is, to
contemporary movie fans, beyond disgusting.
Jolson in The Jazz Singer
“Blackface,” which is captured for posterity
in many films of the first half of the twentieth
century, is a sad reminder to most people
of the ridicule and mistreatment of African-Americans.
Such a thing would be unimaginable today.
Jolson didn’t always use “blackface”
in his act, but because most people of today
know him only by “The Jazz Singer,” his
reputation is often as a symbol of a very
backward time.
Also, Jolson’s singing style, unlike Elvis’
or Frank Sinatra’s or Dean Martin’s, does
not hold up well.
His songs seem rather hokey and schmaltzy.
His singing style is clipped and choppy, not
melodic.
His dance moves look rather silly and dated.
Supposedly, Jolson was not a nice man in real
life either.
Most of his fellow performers say he was deeply
insecure.
According to his contemporary, Groucho Marx,
Jolson was so insecure he would leave the
water faucet running in his dressing room
during his live appearances, so he couldn’t
hear the applause for the previous acts.
During his Broadway appearances, Jolson would
often stop the show in the middle and say
to the audience, “Hey folks, do you wanna
hear the rest of the show or do you want to
hear Jolie sing?”
The crowd would, inevitably, applaud and cheer
for the show to stop.
At this point, “Jolie” (Jolson’s nickname)
would sing some songs to the wildly appreciative
crowd.
One wonders how the rest of the cast of these
shows reacted to this.
What an ego- to pull off a stunt like that-
and routinely yet!
Jolson really wasn’t such a great guy- or
was he?
No one is all-bad (or all-good).
In fact, Jolson was, ironically given the
perception today, an early crusader for the
rights of African-Americans in show business.
For instance, he was instrumental in helping
to promote black playwright Garland Anderson’s
work, which resulted in the first Broadway
production with an all-black cast.
He also attempted to have an all-black dance
team featured in a Broadway show at a time
when black people were banned from Broadway
productions.
As black dancer Jeni LeGon said, “In those
times, it was a ‘black-and-white world.’
You didn’t associate too much socially with
any of the stars.
You saw them at the studio, you know, nice—but
they didn’t invite.
The only ones that ever invited us home for
a visit was Al Jolson and Ruby Keeler.”
In another instance, Jolson read that songwriters
Noble Sissle and Eubie Blake, neither of whom
he knew at the time, had been thrown out of
a restaurant because of their race.
When he heard this, he tracked the pair down
and took them out to dinner and reportedly
told them, “He’d punch anyone in the nose
who tried to kick us out!”
As for his “blackface” persona which seems
to (almost literally) fly in the face of his
apparent true feelings on race, this persona
was often used as a means to introduce white
audiences to black culture, and also to make
fun of the general idea of “white supremacy.”
As such, when black audiences saw “The Jazz
Singer,” rather than boycott it, a Harlem
newspaper, Amsterdam News (today “the oldest
Black newspaper in the country,” according
to their website), stated that The Jazz Singer
was “one of the greatest pictures ever produced,”
and that, “Every colored performer is proud
of him (Jolson).”
Jolson also insisted on the hiring and fair
treatment of black people at a time when this
was an outlandish concept to many in America.
(For example, at the time members of the KKK
are estimated to have accounted for about
15% of the U.S.’s voting-age population.)
He also crusaded for equal rights for African-American
as early as 1911, when he was 25.
Through his very controversial portrayals,
and advocating for black performers, Jolson
helped pave the way for the success of such
legends as Louis Armstrong, Ethyl Waters,
Duke Ellington and Cab Calloway.
As the St. James Encyclopedia of Popular Culture
stated, “Almost single-handedly, Jolson
helped to introduce African-American musical
innovations like jazz, ragtime, and the blues
to white audiences.”
Famed African-American jazz singer Clarence
Henry noted of Jolson, “Jolson?
I loved him.
I think he did wonders for the blacks and
glorified entertainment.”
Beyond the controversy surrounding Jolson,
he was also the first performer to entertain
American troops in WWII.
A few years later, he was also the first to
do the same during the Korean War.
Yes, before Bob Hope!
His break-neck performance schedule in the
latter is also thought to have contributed
to his death soon after.
In his later years, Jolson, for the most part,
led a contented life of semi-retirement.
He remained a huge legend and icon.
Even as late as 1948, with Frank Sinatra,
Bing Crosby, Dean Martin and other singers
on the scene, Jolson was voted America’s
“Most Popular Male Singer.”
Jolson’s life was also the subject of a
very popular film in 1947 called “The Jolson
Story.”
Interestingly, the film actually tries to
explain the reason why “blackface” style
singing was so popular with so many singers
of the earlier part of the century.
While still a bit awkward in retrospect, the
tribute to Jolson and his legacy is quite
fascinating and often touching.
One realizes that while the writers of the
film are trying to explain the reason for
“blackface” to the viewers, one also suspects
they are trying to explain it to themselves.
Al Jolson died shortly after entertaining
the troops in 1950.
He left a wife and two newly-adopted children.
Reportedly, black performers “lined the
way” at his funeral to pay their respects
to the man that had helped popularly introduce
white America to elements of black culture.
In the end, Al Jolson is often seen today
as a “villain,” and it is perhaps an understatement
to say that even to his most staunch supporters,
Jolson remains a controversial figure.
But it would seem the truth is that Al Jolson
was, much like us all, a mixed bag.